do i start what do you want to ebay  completed items [ __ ] i'm going to  show you if you're going to garage sales  you're like oh [ __ ] i see a lot of salt  and pepper shakers then you go to filter  sold and completed items soared highest  price  and then you're like oh [ __ ] 441 600 a  thousand you're not buying this little  [ __ ] bird at a [ __ ] garage so if  you don't know who bought this for 300  salt and pepper shaker [ __ ]  collectors people buy everything  everything could be flipped how do you  think i figured out mug life i was like  i see a lot of mugs at garage sales do  mugs sell for anything search on ebay  mugs completed items sold soared by  [ __ ] price holy [ __ ] there's 88 mugs  there's 63 months there's 96 months then  go buy a bunch of bugs for a quarter  come home look them up educate educate  educate the key to flip life is the  homework you do during the week that you  [ __ ] then leverage on saturday when  you kill it with your [ __ ] knowledge